[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en esta
ocasión discutiremos el inicio de la
fase 1 de los ensayos clínicos en
humanos de dos vacunas contra el virus
de la inmunodeficiencia
humana o el vih
desarrolladas por la compañía de
biotecnología moderna para ello nos
acompaña desde miami florida el doctor
josé gonzález zamora especialista en
enfermedades infecciosas e investigador
de la vacuna de moderna para la
universidad de miami doctor gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
esta farmacéutica utilizará la misma
plataforma que se empleó para
desarrollar la vacuna contra el coi 19
se basarán a técnica del rn mensajero en
qué consistirá esta primera fase doctor
si definitivamente es una muy buena
noticia anunciada por moderna en la cual
va a probar la felicidad y la seguridad
de esta nueva vacuna aérea de mensajero
denominada en 1644 lo que va a hacer en
esta fase de pruebas que es el ensayo
clínico fase 1 en humanos va a probar
cuán efectiva es para producir los
anticuerpos que puedan defender al
organismo frente a una infección por el
vih así que estamos a la expectativa de
resultados preliminares que esperamos
que serían en 10 meses aproximadamente
ahora hay unos 20 ensayos clínicos
contra el vih qué diferencia a este
ensayo que desarrolla moderna con esta
nueva técnica
si hay que destacar que tenemos más de
20 años del desarrollo de vacunas para
el vih lamentablemente hemos tenido
resultados positivos lo que es novedad
de moderna es que utiliza esta nueva
tecnología nunca antes utilizada en el
ámbito de vih para desarrollar una
cantidad de vacuna que pueda ser
efectiva contra esta infección así que
es una novedad que estamos presentando
en gobierna pero también hay que
recordar que existen otras tecnologías
actuales como por ejemplo la de
adenovirus que está siendo aplicado por
jansen a través de su estudio mosaico
que también está destinado a probar
seguridad y eficacia de su vacuna ahora
han pasado 40 años desde que se definió
al sida como la enfermedad causada por
el virus del vih los científicos llevan
años tratando de desarrollar una vacuna
sin éxito cuáles son las dificultades
los retos que plantea el vih doctor
lamentablemente el vih tiene dos
particularidades que lo hacen muy
difícil de tratar uno de ellos que se
integra al adn de los linfocitos y esto
hace que permanezca como una infección
latente de por vida y la otra es su
capacidad de mutación que cambia
persistentemente a través del tiempo y
esto hace muy difícil desarrollar
anticuerpos protectores de forma
absoluta que pueden prevenir una
infección ahora según cifras de 2020 de
la iniciativa internacional de las
vacunas contra el sida más de 38
millones de personas vivían con sida y
un millón y medio contrajo el vih qué
significa esto para la lucha contra el
vih/sida
si definitivamente es una es una es un
brote epidémico que todavía te cobra
bastantes vidas a nivel del mundo y si
hablamos específicamente de regiones del
mundo áfrica todavía sigue siendo la
zona más afectada yo creo que hemos
avanzado muchísimo en el control del vih
tanto con medicamentos antirretrovirales
y también ahora con medicamentos que nos
ayudan a prevenir la infección pero me
parece que todavía falta muchísimo para
desarrollar y uno de ellos que es
fundamental en el futuro el desarrollo
de vacunas así es doctor yo y la última
pregunta es cómo ha ayudado a la
pandemia de kobe 19 a acelerar el
desarrollo de las vacunas de otras
enfermedades y otros virus
si definitivamente en el uso de nuevas
tecnologías como de aire de mensajero
adenovirus y otras ha permitido que
también estas plataformas puedan ser
aplicados a otros ámbitos y también en
el desarrollo de vacunas para virus como
por ejemplo vih pero también otros como
por ejemplo el virus respiratorio
sincicial y otros virus como brin y
banners así que tenemos mucha
expectativa en estas nuevas tecnologías
y yo creo que fue lo positivo del
desarrollo de las ciencias durante esta
pandemia doctor si me queda tiempo para
una última pregunta ahora y le pregunto
qué población va a ser entonces la que
va a participar en esta primera fase de
ensayos
son personas vih negativas entre las
edades de 18 a 50 a 50 años
pues doctor muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información y ojalá pues si
se pueda desarrollar una vacuna eficaz y
con éxito para poder tratar el vih/sida
que es algo además que mucha gente lo
necesite y la comunidad científica
también ha estado trabajando durante
años para poder encontrar una cura
definitiva a este virus doctor
muchísimas gracias como se lo dije
anteriormente y ustedes también gracias
y continúe con nosotros aquí en france
[Música]